the tax base is a community workshop
there's lots them all over the world
nassim is probably one of the biggest if
not the biggest in the UK this we have a
whole load of tools that people can use
for their hobbies or even be even
businesses is the sort of thing that you
perhaps couldn't have to afford to have
in your garage or don't have the space
for that but this is some week you can
join and get access to those sort of
facilities
we're totally run by members we don't
have any members of staff so it's all
run by volunteers and we rely on their
membership fees for buying new tools and
equipment and stuff we've run various
workshops here or all sorts things up
some summer craft related jewelry
related but quite a lot of computer
related workshops we've had raspy Pye
workshops I actually run the Arduino
which are some long with another
maxxbass member there's a really good
for people just sort of get over the
initial hurdle of getting started with
the Arduino so you know if you buy an
Arduino board it's often there's the
certain hurdle you need to get over to
get started we come to one of our
workshops we've got a brain wall planned
out where you don't have to have any
previous knowledge of programming or
electronics and we'll get you started
with that get started flashing the ideas
most electronics projects the software
project so involve embedded circuits
start with and then we work through the
various bits of programming circuits do
to controlling speed of the motor with
something called pulse width modulation
people at the hack space have helped us
out with videos our very first computer
file video was a defender clone that
Michael has made the vending machine Rob
miles is obviously an active member of
the hack space and he's done a lot of
videos here James has done some things
on the Arduino first Spencer has done
some well we've got about 640 numbers
I'm sure you got many more you could
fill there as we go from one around I
think the building were in was actually
an old lace
building but it's now Lots little
businesses in here lots of band practice
rooms for the month with the noise as we
go past certain areas this is the main
interest not in that space and we've got
RFID cards for getting in so after you
come through the street door put your
car in front of here we've got Halloween
and then the door is unlocked we can get
in so welcome to not a compact space
that's all based on Arduino and behind
the scenes there's some code and
obviously MySQL database with all the
all the details of the RFID cards we
have a quite active software team Lee so
behind the scenes that have run writing
one of our membership system and we're
currently running a HS h ms one system
hex based management system one they're
working on version two at the moment
rewriting at all in PHP there laravel
framework this is what we call our comfy
area over this side we've got a museum
of outdated technology so we've got a
Commodore pet up there I think that's
been in the background in your video it
probably has it probably has we've got
quite a few members who are interesting
retrocomputing so you're probably a
separate video on and then at some stage
sometime we're trying to raise a few
more funds for moving into our new area
downstairs
we had some fundraising events and
someone said why not do a sort of
talking to an agents box that collects a
little bit of money and if you put a
coin in a house that's your 2p that's it
it has no idea what you put in is just a
simple coin sensor that's in in in there
it's based on a Raspberry Pi detects a
coin going in and just say a random
phrase it's sometimes miss announcements
trying to solicit money off visitors
particularly Wednesday overnight but
you'll find all sorts of odd things like
this around the hack space this is an
old al DSL modem over to see the
Raspberry Pi there it's been fitted into
a little amplifier circuit to getting
sound there if you press the button on
it replays the last message depressing
enough times it
okay so we have all sorts of equipment
that people get access to so this is
actually a computer-controlled
embroidery machine so members can do
designs at home bring their designing on
a memory stick use the software on this
computer to convert into the right
formats to do the embroidery on this
machine there's a number of machines
that you need to do an induction with us
before you can gain access and we record
who's done the training through the RFID
access system so if I put my card in
there they'll just say not inducted and
I won't be able to turn the machine on
so I've looked on the training but if
someone else comes in and has done the
training they can put the car in here
and turn the machine on it and they can
obviously use it all of this has been
made in-house by members against based
on an Arduino an RFID car reader and
then we've got our laser cut box over
that area we've got lots of crafts and
art materials lots of textile materials
that's of interest as some members we
also have another group of members who
look after these vending machines so
we've now got two vending machines this
particular one is featured in a computer
file video before it's all on the same
rfid saxis system as the machines and
the doors the last time we came that was
full of bits of electronics yeah it used
to be but we found that the foodstuff
sells better and brings a bit more money
into the hack space this area we've got
woodworking tools
so in this area for all of the dusty
woodworking tool so we've got a big
table saw here so it was a couple of
members over there using the planer fit
yourself so here we've got our laser
cutter this is used for cutting acrylic
plywood MDF they'll also cut paper card
leather it will engrave glass it will
engrave slate we do get a lot of people
joining just to get access to this
machine because this is not sort of
thing you could have in your garage at
home wrong knotless you've got lots of
space and lots of money these cost about
six thousand pounds as soon as you
powers up the head will also date them
in the corner over there makes quite a
lot of noise the noise is actually the
extractor so the extractors willing to
suck all the smoke that's in here out of
the way okay so this is the software we
use it works using DXF files just going
to quickly import a file there's a
little bit of tidying up when you still
on this fart it comes in as a number of
separate points here and then we can
send it down to the laser cutter once we
put the appropriate powers and speeds in
and then the laser cutter will cut the
part out so in this area we've got our
metalwork tools we've got band saws
because you metalwork we have a lathe if
anyone's doing metal turning we've got a
Bridgeport mill milling machine and at
the back we've got welding equipment
we've got MIG welder and a TIG welder
and over this side here we've got a ball
tomaters hacksaw so you can if you've
got your large piece of metal to cut up
there's no need to do it by hands this
is a nice parallel cut you put your
metal in here and it's or through and
then turned itself off when it's
finished these old railway clocks have
come from the work place of one of our
members so one of them there we've got
running with a the time on it we're not
got this one running the moment so
nothing in hack space is currently on
two floors and the both ones directly
below the other but unfortunately a bit
of a walk around to get between the two
levels but eventually we hope to have
enough money to put in our own staircase
our own or our own lift even between the
two floors okay so this is our new area
and in this area here we've got some
more computer-controlled equipment so
we've got a computer-controlled
milling machine here we had someone just
recently making some parts for guitars
on here which looked fantastic and over
the far end we've got a
computer-controlled
lathe in the middle we got a 3d printer
do I get see much use then no the
computer-controlled milling machine the
computer control they don't get an awful
lot of use and I think the problem with
that is that we don't have any induction
program for those so if you want to use
those you got to do a lot of reading up
a lot of self-training perhaps watching
YouTube videos to learn how to draw the
parts and then to get them the parts
through the tool paths for cutting them
out this computer might be a bit dated
but it's powerful enough to run this
blaze it's all of the lighting in this
new area is computer control we've got
arduino 'he's running the show down here
it's all in this control box and there's
actually a web interface you can use to
turn on individual lights in this area I
didn't develop this is all done by
another member so we can turn on
individual lights on and off so if I
just select one in here sure which one
it is but well the lights will go off if
I do that yes one over there anyway
quite a few members in particular like
having to go to a web site to turn the
lights on and off
whilst this you know it's a great use of
technology some people didn't like that
so we had one member who built a light
switch whilst it looks like an ordinary
light switch it's just got a USB power
sly type going into there we've actually
got a pro soon there I've got an esp8266
one off we're an opera for perfect
organization if anyone's looking to find
the hack space there's a couple of good
websites to take a look at one is wiki
dot hackerspaces
dot org where you can find hack spaces
all over the world if you're in the UK
is www.spacetelescope.org transcribed